before we get into these today this
there was quite a few comments on
yesterday's video that I think I'm Dan
you you you might want to address
exactly the video that was about loot
crate's in battlefront - huge
controversy around that the one thing
that our viewers were fixated on that's
a sweet sweet nectar let me tell you why
I'm growing this neckbeard I'm growing
this neckbeard because it is no-shave
November in support of men's mental
health so maybe instead of writing out a
comment that says hey man shave your
neck beard or something like that head
on over to Movember combat au and just
donate first up let's talk about getting
you some free stuff that's right if you
want as a grush and pylon construct
construct a pilot instructor pile you
know what just keep I'm never playing it
you can get Starcraft 2 for free right
now after the surprise announcement that
Starcraft 2 is going free to play at
Blizzcon earlier this month the game is
now free on PC if you haven't played
Starcraft 2 before you can play through
the entire wings of Liberty campaign and
all current and upcoming called
commanders are also free to play up to
level 5 the Rayna Kerrigan and Atanas
are free to level up for ever and ever
the free version also gives you access
to ranked multiplayer which includes all
the units from wings of Liberty part of
the swarm and a legacy of the void to
unlock it though you'll need to earn 10
first wins of the day metals in unranked
or vers AI play if you've already bought
the wings of Liberty campaign before
October 31st you can get the heart of
the swarm expansion for free just by
logging in between November 8th and
December 8th
if the game takes you fancy you can pick
up each of the subsequent expansions for
$15 each or is a bundle for $40 player
unknowns battlegrounds is currently
testing a bunch of new stuff well for
the next maybe hour or so like vaulting
and cool new ballistics that make the
bullets pull down on the ground some
enterprising players there have used a
24-hour window to dot in mind the test
build and they've found some pretty
interesting things develop a blue hole
has been tasing the addition of a new
map set in a desert for a few months and
now it looks like we've got our first
look at the maps layout thanks to Reddit
user man biz farts biz farts real name
unknown posted the image you're looking
at right now meanwhile another user with
a thankfully normal-ish
r7s has uncovered the images of some new
vehicles including a jetski
minibus and pickup truck as well as what
appears to be a new gun there's still no
word on when the new app is coming to
pub G but as soon as we know you'll know
so keep tuning in co-op Judy World War
two is all set to get its
microtransaction starting November 21st
after a delay said microtransactions
will come in the form of call of duty
points which players can buy with
real-world money if you picked up the
digital edition you'll find 1,100 Call
of Duty points are already in your Call
of Duty wallet when the system is
implemented as for why the points
haven't been available so far actually
delayed the launch of microtransactions
in order to fix the launch issues first
while we aren't sure what the points can
be spent on just yet in infinite warfare
they could be used to purchase supply
drops for multiplayer and zombies crates
in other Cod news the PC update is out
now so if you want to know everything
that's come along with that ahead to a
story on site that is everything we've
got for you today do let us know what
you thought about today's stories and do
you remember that this weekend we're
doing extra life there's 72 hours not
just honest that would be insane we're
kicking off in the US and then it will
be coming over to Australia where you'll
be seeing our faces for 24 straight
hours oh boy
and then let's go back to the US for 12
hours and then the UK it's gonna round
it out with 12 hours so make sure you
tune in see some cool games donate for a
good cause and we'll be there so we hope
to see you there too but we'll also be
here tomorrow for more news so we'll see
them I don't think that's gonna help me
spell better anymore
guess won't ever know that hey thank you
for coming on my new talk-show mini mic
with Dan crowd today on mini mic we've
got Jessica McDonald how are you hi so
Omni mic on mini mic we try to get that
microphone as close as we can to our elf
and just speak into them Oh God